one episode is out in the world how
are you feeling about the real houses of
salt lake city finally
people have seen it relief you know it's
like you have all this
anticipation for a long time again you
don't know what
you're going to be received as by the
rest of the world so it's definitely
you know a little bit um daunting to say
the least and so
i feel a huge sense of relief having the
first episode out it was
amazing for me to just be like check
that off done and you know what you film
but you don't know what everybody else
filmed
you don't know what everybody's saying
in their confessional interviews
did anything in that first episode
surprise you i mean
i don't know if there is anything
shocking in there i
you know as you mentioned i don't know
what happens
when i walk out the door i don't know
what happens with
you know the other women how aware were
you
that the the conversation was leading to
hospital smell
double amputation what do you want me to
do not say you smell like hospital when
she gets
both legs amputated i don't know what
you want me to do about your aunt her
legs are gone
that was a housewives first
um i would imagine that's a first for
many certainly at first for me
um so obviously i knew that
that there was an issue and that there
was a conflict between mary and jen
because nobody who wasn't aware of it
let me just put it that way
i don't think any of us really realized
the level that it had escalated to
so you know the whole thing was was a
bit surprising where it went
and i guess it makes a lot more sense to
me now why they were so angry at each
other because
i didn't really get it to be honest what
can you tell me about where this goes
with and how you get roped into it
you're gonna go with mary who's your
grandfather
what i can say that's just true of me in
life in general
is i don't believe that anyone should
dictate
who someone else can or cannot be
friends with that's just not my vibe
i've been friends with a lot of people
who don't care for one another and i i
don't
engage in nasty conversations about the
others so
um to me it that's a little bit
shocking like what's the big deal i can
be friends with two people who aren't
friends as long as i'm
um loyal to both of them that is
possible
that leads me into the other kind of uh
friction we saw in that premiere
[Music]
did lisa just blow me off what do you
make of the whole
lisa i don't know her heather drama
that one i think i can't really comment
on without disclosing things i shouldn't
be talking about yet
but we'll get there it's just not time
yet okay what you're telling me is that
this
it does not end at that uh dinner table
you don't remember me or know me at all
but you remember me flashing i don't get
it
keep coming who's next who's next you
will see tensions running
through the course of time
with everybody this is just the
beginning
we're just one episode in you know i was
looking at the interviews you've done so
far
you said there is one liar on this cast
you got to name names who's the liar who
do we need to be watching out for
so i can't name names yet
because i can't i can't give everything
away
um what i believe i said was there's at
least
one liar i think there may be multiple
liars there's one that is
100 confirmed for me because i've
caught the multitude of lies but um
there are still some other things that
aren't quite adding up
so i think that there's probably at
least two
liars out there i don't know who the
second one is
um but we shall see and again if i'm
wrong on the first which i'm 99.9
sure i'm not i will own it and apologize
but i
uh there's definitely a lot of lying for
me
handling more of a group setting like
this was
a lot and uh i was surprised because
engaging with people one-on-one is in
seeing how they
behave when they're in a group setting
are two very different things
okay so what you're saying is one-on-one
the women were showing you maybe one
face in in front of the group somewhere
showing another
pretty much or either it's it's not
necessarily being too faced
less of a two-faced thing more of a true
colors thing
probably that i mean there's definitely
some two-faced stuff too don't don't
misunderstand me i'm not denying that
but more yeah more of
like a true colors like that's just not
something i expected you know it was
surprising
did anyone on that note disappoint you
some actions came out you went wow i
can't believe we went there
yes 100 will you give me one name
meredith
one name i'm keeping it tight for right
now
we'll talk again a little bit down the
road get get a couple more episodes in
and then we can
dig a little deeper okay as we approach
the reunion or maybe even after you film
the reunion because i would love to know
what your mind is like after you've sat
down and hash some of this stuff
out are you keeping notes uh of things
you're like oh gotta bring that up
gotta make sure we button that up yes
there is a lot to button up i have a lot
of issues and
just knowing what i do know about what's
gone on
in between all the other women
i'm barely scratching the surface with
my issues a lot went on behind my back
and i'm going to be watching right along
with the rest of the world
trying to decipher who is really a
friend and who is
not well we we got that vibe a little
bit when your tagline came out
jealousy is a disease to which i say
get well soon is that a message pointed
at one costar in particular
the whole group um
it's a message that that's pointed at
more than one jealousy brings out an
ugly side of people and yes
get well soon speedy recovery because i
don't like it
oh just don't go to a hospital because
then you can't be around mary
uh but know that what you said there of
kind of separating yourself from drama
one when the trailer came out you have
this line where you go thank you i'm
just engaging
is that kind of your mo you don't like
to be in the mud
if stuff is getting to a place where you
feel uncomfortable you're like i'm out
of here
resolve this yourself i mean yes and no
i guess for me by virtue of
my business i am traveling a lot and
i think a lot of the times before you
know
the hits the fans so to speak i'm
already on to the next city
so uh that didn't happen here
so it's like yeah you got to deal with
it and
uh and that's fine you know i can hold
my own
it's you know i'm not a pushover by any
stretch
but i i do demand that people speak to
me with a certain level of respect and
self-control
and if they're not going to do that i am
going to leave i will not allow somebody
to
yell and scream and swear at me that's
not acceptable
all right moving off the women to your
personal story your family
brooks the breakout star of the real
housewives of salt lake city
are you guys ready yeah are you ready
i've been ready for the past like 15
minutes let's go
what does it mean to you to see this
great response to your kid
it's incredible there is honestly there
is like
nothing that could make me happier than
seeing um brooks or any of my three
children
thrive and seeing this moment for brooks
is
really very special to me it is be
honest with me
was part of his decision to take a
semester off mom is filming housewives
and i gotta be around for that
so i mean of course there's a little bit
of that that comes into play but the
reality of the matter is
brooks was um working on his brand and
he also was coming to you know help me
during a very difficult time in my life
so there were all kinds of factors that
came into play there
i mean it was very positive thing for me
to have
i'll tell you that i think probably only
eagle-eyed viewers noticed this but jen
shaw is wearing some brooks mark's
athleisure wear
in the premiere episode andy cohen has
teased that brooks's fashion show
is a moment that we're gonna be waiting
for to see
this season brooks's fashion show to me
was absolutely iconic and
i i don't want to ruin it you'll have to
watch and see
but it was like it was the moment i will
never
ever ever ever forget for good reasons
bad reasons all of the above oh
good okay i was like
moving to the other side of your
personal story the teasers put a lot of
focus on the state of your marriage
if you're not getting it from home
you're going to go somewhere else
i don't know if it's going to work but i
know this is not working
we know there was a divorce filing and a
dismissed divorce filing before cameras
even went up
was there any trepidation of airing out
your real personal business in front of
millions of people
yeah i mean of course i'd be crazy if i
didn't say yes to that
um you know seth and i have had a
long history of um
of separations and reconciliations over
the years
it was not something we were ever public
about because our children never knew
but we had separated we had dated other
people at times
our children did not ever know we were
always living in the same home
and um becoming empty nesters sort of
put us in a place where we were really
forced to evaluate
what path we were going to go down and
so you know people question is reality
to be
real and um there is nothing more real
than what i went through on this show
i think and get a little teary saying it
even but
it's real and uh it's it's intense
and you'll see it all play out i've been
very very private about our uh marital
state
i really had not told any of my friends
and my children
just found out before we started filming
does getting choked up now is it
looking forward to everyone learning
that you went through this
is it thinking about what you've
overcome why do those emotions
come up that's actually a good question
i should probably explore further with
my therapist
now i think that it's a combination of
of all of the above marriage takes an
immense amount of commitment and immense
amount of work
and to sometimes look back and you say
like
maybe i could have done this differently
maybe i could have done that differently
you know
did i screw this up did i screw that up
was
shielding my children from all this a
horrible mistake all along you know you
just start to question every
choice you made and that's the process
i've been
going through is reevaluating looking at
it you know all my decisions all my
choices and
questioning in episode two we learn
that we've met you in a moment of
separation that you and seth
are not together at at the moment what
kind of ups and downs are we gonna see
uh for the two of you and is there a
resolution at the end whether that's
divorce or not
um so yes there is a resolution at the
end i cannot
speak to what that is um but it does go
one way or another
and um yes we are separated like
legitimately separated for the first
time
in separate homes and we now can be in
our own homes
and sort of try to figure out what
direction
we want to go and can we make this work
or can't we
you know should we move forward with a
divorce should we
um be seeing only each other should we
be dating other people
should we separate there all these
questions are out there that we have to
figure out what was it like then
navigating being in this
group of some old friends some new
friends
who you got to pick and choose what
you're sharing with them
and i from the teasers we know whitney
starts to speculate
i'm confused watching meredith and seth
be touchy philly and i've heard just
seeing someone else you're trying to
figure it out yourself so to have to
explain yourself to other people has to
be difficult
yeah i mean honestly that that was
something that was
very upsetting to me to be throwing
things out there when you don't really
know if they're true or false you don't
know what's going on you don't know
what's rumor
um is upsetting very upsetting
so we'll watch and see like i said
earlier there's a lot of conversation
that went on about me behind my back
i'm very curious to see who's
responsible for what
um and then we'll see you know perhaps
uh
i misunderstood some things but i doubt
it
god i just want you to tell me who this
lying two-faced
person is i gotta know
i guess i gotta keep watching to find
out
you would never hand me your phone i'm
done with this company because you're
hiding something there seem to be
some a little bit of a trust issue
situation that will unfold
seth kind of accuses you of hiding
something were you hiding something
are we gonna see you hiding something i
can't
tell you what seth thinks i'm hiding or
not but no
there's nothing to hide seth and i had a
long history of ups and downs in our
relationship a history of
multiple separations a history of dating
other people
so what am i hiding
when you've entered these periods of
separation do you set like ground rules
of like
these are the what you can do this is
what you can't do or is it like a
free-for-all no rules situation
so that has varied
and um i will say my advice to anybody
is if there's a question mark on what
your roles are
set them straight it's a lot easier that
way
seth makes quite a few cracks about your
sex life
i'm totally overworked and under sex
okay that's not that's not even funny
that's not nice
it's true we're gonna be truthful
how do you feel about that being aired
out on television
i don't really care you know what first
of all
everyone has to understand that seth is
filled with sarcasm um
as is most of my family i'm probably the
straightest shooter of anyone in my
family
i think you're pretty sarcastic too i
feel like your sarcasm came across in
episode one
hashtag blessed we've got a lot of
season left to
unfold what are you most excited for the
viewers to see
in what remains of season one of salt
lake city so
i'm excited from my own personal
standpoint i'm excited for everybody to
see
um you know how i engage with my
family um how i engage in business
i am very serious about my business like
it comes across as probably everything
to me on the outside but at the end of
the day
my family is the number one priority in
my life
um so from that standpoint i'm really
excited for
people to see all of that on the the
flip side of uh
looking forward to stuff is there
anything in particular you're really
dreading
the viewers seeing or having to relive
yourself yeah
any you know heated moments in my
particularly in my family will be hard
for me to
to watch again um you know obviously
any heated moments with the women i may
not really particularly
enjoy but that won't be as trying for me
as watching
arguments with my family that will be
difficult anything that
is you know within my family is going to
be the hardest thing for me
did you already have that kind of
stone in your stomach moment when the
trailer came out and we had there's that
scene of seth like packing his bag
and storming out yeah
okay simple enough simple enough
well that's all i have for you it was
great to finally connect
congratulations the show is so great and
i can't wait to see more
thank you so much for having me and uh
we will have to reconnect down the road
when i can tell you more
yeah when you can name names say who the
liar is who's two-faced i gotta
we'll we'll dig into it all and then
you'll have to pull out your notebook of
all the things you
to get answered at the reunion
the list is already very long and we're
only in episode one
so we've got 55 minutes of television
out there and we've already got a list i
love it
you